so that they could then get a warrant to
spy on Americans associated with
president Trump's campaign that's what
it looks like it looks like is not
enough basis to appoint a special
counsel all right but the door is still
left open isn't it Ben I mean the door
is still open but I gotta say I'm with
sessions on this one mean sessions I
assume has seen more evidence or at
least as much evidence as the members of
Congress have and he's the one who has
to appoint a special counsel and he's
also the one who has to say I'm so
compromised that I have to appoint
someone who is not me
right the reason you appoint a special
counsel he's hired to do the job right
we're paying him to do the job the
reason to appoint a special counsel is
because the idea would be that he is too
biased to investigate the issue that he
is that he's looking at right now I
don't think that's that's right and I
think that he is correct I mean just
putting on my lawyer hat here you the
the idea that you're suspicious of
something does not mean but tweets that
we just read does it sort of make it
look like the president is influencing
his decision here um well it makes it
look like he's influenced decision the
other way right min sessions is not
actually appointing a special counsel
and Trump obviously well I wasn't
indicating influencing either way but
does that make Jones have to push back
harder I don't think so I mean I think
that if session I'd wouldn't want to
challenge sessions honesty on this and
feel like okay well Trump tweeted
something therefore sessions went ahead
and did I mean we've seen sessions buck
him a few times already